all right welcome everybody we're
getting right to it because time is of
the essence a verdict has been reached
in the johnny depp versus amber heard
defamation trial
i am thrilled that it's finally going to
be over and in a few days we're going to
be moving on to the january 6th uh house
uh investigation hearings and etc etc
we're finally getting to the end of this
the verdict will be read in 15 minutes
and in addition to that
i'm also genuinely curious what the
outcome is going to be because some of
us have been following this for a long
time
there are a whole bunch of different
implications and considerations for this
so we will know the verdict
to be read in about 14 minutes i'm so
glad that you were here
um i can people want to comment on what
they expect or whatever the case may be
you are free to do that but welcome
welcome welcome we are finally getting
to the end of this let's listen into
what's happening uh even though the jury
is not supposed to be watching but we
all know that yeah you know but we all
think that maybe juries not this one
because this one is very ethical but
some juries may watch uh
dottie let me just go back to you this
is a first time chat thank you from
twitch first all right so a lot of
twitch action happening there we're
going to have another stream here inside
the courthouse and we are just moments
away moments away
i want to say thank you to debbie cruz
edna cabral
and travis stone for signing up on my
website
joinpakman.com you are very early new
members one two and three and also
thanks to jen here for the twitch prime
subscription a number of decisions that
the jurors have to make
and we are standing by indeed
for the verdict i believe that this is
now live in the courtroom and uh just
about 10 minutes until this is
read
it's going to be quite a scene quite a
scene that i can assure you voicemails
coming in let's see if any of these are
about the trial
hey david tyler from new jersey i just
want to point out
you need to check out this new laura
ingraham comment about um
marijuana legalization of marijuana
oh yeah we have a segment on today's
show uh wherein
uh laura ingram talks about how cannabis
is the real reason for the shootings
that's the real reason so she says it is
uh very very wild wild times
not something i agree with but we do
look at the science of cannabis and
aggression
um
if you don't care about the
the verdict
you don't have to watch i mean watching
this stream right now is optional you
know you don't you don't have to do it
i'm glad to have anybody here who's
interested but don't feel as though you
are required required
to watch because you are not you are not
i've got to add my virtue oh you know
what i actually have a ton of great new
clips for my soundboard which i just
haven't added yet
kofi
yeah that's a good one
uh
let's see
this rusher thing with trump and
yep
gonna see some
stick sticks coming out on one very
powerful ones if you care about law and
auto law and auto
i got to get all of these in i got to
get them and we're going to get them in
very soon because it's just an absolute
must it's an absolute must
um
let's see here
super chat's coming in do you think the
live streaming of trials is a net
positive or negative for society i think
it it's a very little impact for society
other than i think it's good for people
to know what goes on in real courtrooms
rather than fake tv and movie courtrooms
so in that sense
i sort of think
it's a net positive that's uh that's
that's kind of my instinct
but reasonable people can disagree
that's the beautiful thing about
america
in comes amber heard
and we will have a verdict read
a momentarily i believe that's her
sister who the hell knows i don't know
what her name is
um
and then someone else here
we are standing by very very strongly
for this
verdict will be read in mere moments
ladies and gentlemen mere mere moments
um
when is the next town hall june 14th
june 14th is the next town hall
it is the verdict may not be uh you can
have a split verdict because there's a
number of decisions that the jurors will
have to to make and you'll see this as
the verdict is read it's not like an all
for one and one for all sort of thing uh
defamation cases are a little bit
different and you're going to see that
um momentarily
although
you know there may be unanimity here
we're going to see that very very soon
um
whitney is amber heard's sister exactly
i don't know i don't know any of this
stuff
um
i'm just curious about the result i mean
it's been a long long long trial for
sure
uh let's see is the coupon code obama
still working of course obama yeah that
always works
we might do maxell co soon mexico or
mexicon it's hard to know exactly how to
pronounce that
thank you to indeciso
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number five today everybody is standing
by
amber heard is in the courtroom the
verdict will be read at 3 p.m eastern
time which is
uh nine minutes from now nine minutes
from now i plan to be live on tuesday
with more primary results i believe
we've got
texas and a number of other different
states which could be
could be pretty important states in the
context of 2022 that will be on tuesday
many many streams planned and coming up
very soon
i want to say thank you to
ani
sepakov for signing up at joinpakman.com
of course you can always sign up there
yep coupon code obama
very much appreciate that
you haven't missed
the verdict
the verdict will be read in the next 10
minutes
um
people are saying david please turn off
subscriber only mode
uh
no why would i do that of course we're
not turning off subscriber only mode
subscriber only mode is on deliberately
why would why would why on earth would i
turn that off that's crazy
is there a portal in the courtroom not
that i'm aware of
not that i'm aware of let's see if we
have audio
we do not have audio yet
uh
yeah
we're going to be seeing all of it very
very soon
it's all happening
um
other
voicemails
coming in
nothing nothing at this moment about the
trial super chat can you have a poll for
us to guess his verdict you know the
reason i'm not doing a poll is because
there are so many legal questions to be
answered there's really no one poll that
could encompass all of it and it's just
kind of complicated
david your polite backhanded slapdown of
the email where you explained how large
your show was wonderful stay safe sir i
don't remember that one to be honest
i don't remember that one yeah i don't
even know when people talk about
subscriber only mode on twitch it's
follower only mode and that's enabled
and on youtube it's subscriber only mode
and that is enabled it just cuts down on
spam it's just a very simple anti-spam
method
uh it's it's not like a major big deal
or anything like that
um not particularly controversial either
i should say
a lot of people asking
how could amber heard possibly pay
the amounts
that she's being sued for she doesn't
have that much money that's true
and you know
getting a judgment is one thing
being able to collect is another thing
those are two different things and i'm
sure there will be time for the lawyers
to assess that if and when the time
comes now where is johnny depp is johnny
depp expected to be in the courtroom he
must be right
i believe that the you you would imagine
you you would imagine
let's see what's being said here gone on
they're all
taking their places inside right now um
waiting for this to get underway i mean
linda you've watched this closely the
whole time just as close as anyone and
am i right that you know right around
three o'clock sharp we're going to see
something happen because this judge
likes to stick to schedule she is
absolutely a purist she wants the
schedule she has probably told the
jurors that they're coming right out of
three to get their belongings ready and
uh yes she we will have that verdict
right here at the long time network
stacy absolutely
so here's a good question that came in
from someone's goat love that name on
youtube she said are we ever going to
see the jury or are they never going to
be shown for their protection um linda
we wouldn't see the jury
tell our viewers yes we we don't get to
see juries in the united states of
america we kind of protect their
identity in the courtroom and i'm
looking at the courtroom right now
stacey i'm looking at the picture of the
attorneys all seated i think that i
think that's amber heard in the quran
and god bless
the united states
wow i guess uh
i guess johnny depp is in london some
people are saying can't identify
themselves they could actually have
their own press conference they can talk
to the media will this is a good
question will the jury be issuing any
dick tats yeah that was a big issue over
the weekend at a number of the rallies
that we covered that that was wild
thanks to juno rocks for the twitch
prime subscription you're number seven
today
uh we'll uh uh oh hold on other super
chats isn't there a counter suit filed
by herd how does that work will there'll
be another whole trial no this trial is
both
the suit and the countersuit it's all
here and we will get all those verdicts
momentarily johnny depp is in the uk
playing with his band
all he ever wanted was to get away from
her so i don't blame him
david just wanted to see if anything
else happened after the marjorie taylor
green trial i haven't heard anything
yeah she's going to be she was allowed
to be on the ballot that was the that
was the result
um of that uh
of that hearing for those who may not
have known you may not have known but
that was the that was the outcome
other voicemails coming in
let's see
dave
since i become more and more concerned
about the right wing going crazy and
attacking
with guns
when they start losing elections
uh i wonder what the uh uh joe biden
options have for calling in military
fbi
you know law enforcement whatever to
keep people from first of all being
intimidated wow yeah no that's that's
that's absolutely huge actually
uh and it's a question we are going to
be looking at it's a complicated
question i would say
but certainly a question nonetheless
thanks to eponymous bay and la luz bueno
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers eight and nine if you're just
joining us we are moments away
finally from the conclusion of this
trial finally the verdict will be read
in three minutes assuming they're on
schedule
derek says i hope this trial becomes a
republican talking point would love to
hear trump try to say
defamation yeah that cephe
cepha hyde that that would actually be
uh
be pretty interesting where is my
glitches
hold on
gl oh here we go i've had more
investigations than jesse james billy
that could
no more drop
drop boxes
we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel
a rhino named mitt romney
then he went donald trump yeah donald
trump truth essential
president donald j trump i don't know
why donald is one of the funniest ones
uh okay with reality tv dead hollywood
found a new product well it's coming to
an end soon i am sort of curious there
are some youtube channels
that were almost non-existent before
this trial and exploded thanks to this
trial what did they do after it you know
i was thinking back my friends to
in 2016 there were some channels that
were just bernie they were all they
barely existed beforehand there was a
woman whose name i don't remember whose
channel was just about bernie
and then
the channel just died as soon as bernie
was out do you guys remember what that
channel was there was this woman in
2016.
she was a little kooky yeah
i don't i don't remember her name
yeah i don't know what happens to those
channels when they're basically just
they exist around a one what we call a
tent pole event
uh no it wasn't a dude it was a woman
okay anyway nobody remembers that's fine
um did i hear marjorie taylor green's
peach tree dish comment yes yesterday
yesterday i um talked about that
david on my my third day of covet
recovery and want to remind you and your
audience that the pandemic is still here
stay safe out there
an important message very very important
message
thank you to k shreds for the twitch
prime subscription you are number 10.
if you're just joining us you have
missed nothing the verdict will be read
momentarily momentarily scheduled for
right now
johnny is finally getting exposed for
his lies well that's one perspective
others believe it's amber heard who has
been exposed for her lies
ultimately it will be up to the jury of
seven to decide
the jury of seven will decide
momentarily
uh any minute now quite frankly any
minute now we are going to find that out
um
are there any coupon codes other than
obama sure yeah you can use the coupon
code sad trump on my website sad trump
at joinpakman.com
honestly use whatever coupon code you
want all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen on standby where we have seen
crowds growing supporters um and so
forth as we get ready for this verdict
to be read it is about three o'clock
all right are we ready for the jury
yes your honor yes all right just uh for
everybody in the gallery reminder this
that this is a court of law
uh and uh regardless of the verdict i
will not tolerate any outburst
whatsoever no outbursts
thanks to shoegazer for the twitch prime
subscription
you haven't missed it the verdict is
coming right now i know people don't
like the resolution the resolution is
low on every single one of these streams
unfortunately
every single one you haven't missed it
yet please proceed governor exactly we
are standing by
the paperwork has been delivered to the
judge who will now review it
[Applause]
thanks to simon reed for gifting a
subscription on my website thank you
simon appreciate that
the judge reviewing the verdict
[Music]
the attorneys are approaching
i wonder if the dude is it possible the
judge will tell the attorneys what the
verdict is right here probably not right
i have not covered any trials where at
this point the attorneys are asked to
approach that is interesting however
our audio has not been cut it's the
court that has reduced the audio feed
everybody relax it will come right back
on
during these sidebar conversations they
just mute the audio
all right again you're looking live
okay
all right ladies and gentlemen the jury
what i need i need you to do i need to
give some respects back to you
um when you find a defamatory statement
one one or more
you need to fill out the compensatory
damages it has to be at least a dollar
for compensatory damages and up to
whatever you feel the damages should be
it sounds like they didn't now it's
frozen
and we've lost the audio
back to the
liberation room and do that for me okay
wow
the jury did not fill in the the dollar
amount of the damages
now it sounds like that is a clue that
they did find some damages for someone
but we don't know what
wow
till we hear back from them don't go too
far okay
thank you
wow now i have to tell you it's
conceivable it's conceivable that they
haven't even discussed the compensatory
damages it could be days or hours or
minutes wow 310 315 uh not so fast there
was a little sidebar going on with the
attorneys in the front apparently the
jurors didn't fill out the damages
section
the judge now sending them back to
complete
this special verdict form literally like
a worksheet that they need to fill out
they didn't put it these are the people
deciding everything
these are the people deciding who goes
to prison for life case that somebody
won their defamation claims right now
the fact that they didn't fill out the
compensatory damages award i think may
bode well for johnny depp the judge said
it has to be at least a dollar usually
you see if somebody wins you have to
fill an award either that or somehow
they both won which i don't think is
likely but he was the one that didn't
ask for damages if you recall he said
i'm not seeking damages she asked for i
think it was 350 000 damages so it
sounds like someone won
it could be johnny depp because the jury
may have telegraphed it by not filling
out an award for damages wow since so
that's interesting since johnny depp
didn't ask for damages the jury might
have said depp wins but he didn't ask
for damages so we're not giving him any
money that's that's right that's what
that's what it could sound like
now in the very unlikely event that they
just forgot to do that section and they
actually did intend for some kind of
damages we had a question from viewers
earlier which is what happens if there's
a verdict say against against amber
heard and there's a judgment awarded for
johnny depp and amber heard doesn't have
that money whether it's 50 million
dollars whether it's 20 million dollars
whether it's 10 million dollars what
happens if she doesn't have that money
linda well you know we have that in many
civil cases where the person that gets
the verdict they don't have the
defendant doesn't have the money right
uh you can pursue her it goes it could
be a claim that follows her around for
the rest of her life
with it it gets docketed it gets logged
she could discharge it and bankruptcy
assuming it's against her we're making a
lot of assumptions mate yeah and what
does it mean that he didn't ask for
damages given that he was suing for 50
million or for that
that doesn't that doesn't totally make
sense either well we'll we'll see
whether this was just they forgot to
write it in or whether they have not yet
discussed this
a bash brannigan asks via super chat do
you think either depp or heard can
recover their career i think they can i
mean listen mel gibson sort of went back
to act again
after his horrible incident with
anti-semitism
jury convicts david pakman on his
blatantly illegal discount codes yeah
that would be i am ready for that civil
suit
uh my membership program is suing me for
defamation because i give such large
discounts that the membership program
feels that it's not being taken
seriously
uh mark garagos will be representing me
almost time for a mega pint via super
chat
many many are feeling that way many are
feeling that way
so we are at a brief interlude here if
you're just joining us the jury rendered
a verdict
and didn't fill out the damages
compensatory damages they left the
dollar amount blank the jury has been
sent back to their room to fill it out
it might be that they're going to fill
it out in a minute or maybe not or maybe
they didn't even think about it and it
could be days longer they might have
thought we're out of here and it could
be days longer if they have not yet
thought about that
which is wild
jury to award 500 pacman memberships for
damages absolutely
david sir which is your favorite sound
bite obama gazpacho police or pillow
suing all machines i think it's gotta be
pillow right it's i don't know of any
funnier clips than this we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah
i think it's probably that for comedic
reasons
um david sir get the gavel out i threw
the gavel out actually
there's a tail over the top of your ear
there is which ear
oh my god
let me see
there we go hold on let me adjust my
hair is that better
all right i think we fixed it
thank you very much super chats are
dumping in david please have a zero
damages discount code that discounts
zero percent there's an idea
yeah there's there's a beautiful
beautiful idea
um
how many people did the memorial day
discount code let's see that's a good
question the coupon code was big voting
you know trump how trump says big water
surrounded by water
big water we did a coupon code on
memorial day big voting 22.
and let me see here
[Music]
169 people took advantage of the big
voting 22 discount code
on memorial day which was a beautiful
beautiful discount code and a beautiful
day i should say
um
yeah
what did i do i actually so uh oh did i
celebrate may 25th yeah so man people
may or may not know but may 25 is a big
day
in uh
argentinian history
the first independent government
was formed on uh may 25th in the 1800s
the early 1800s so on may 25th many
argentinians get together it's it's kind
of like a uh you know sort of pseudo
fourth of july type of event
and i did indeed participate in a
beautiful
may 25th event it fell in the middle of
the week so
a bunch of argentinians i know mostly in
queens
did an event this weekend
um
at the great
flushing meadows park
uh
environmentally ravaged i would say
um but it was a great it was a great
thing and you know grilling you got to
have grilling there's no argentinian
event without grilling grilling is an
absolute must
hopefully the jury leaves the door
propped yes well said right
um
i want to say thank you to dwayne
robertson dwayne just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama
and his new member number 13 today very
much appreciate that
uh it's a beautiful beautiful day and a
beautiful thing i would say
other voicemails that are coming in
the eggman commenting on john voigt
dave i love john voigt okay as an actor
um mickey donovan
have you ever seen anaconda that old
horrible movie look he's great okay i
can separate the man the art from his
politics i can't do that with mel gibson
okay
is there a line there why do i love john
voice so much i don't care what he says
okay he's mickey donovan he's one of the
greatest actors of all time
mel gibson i think is a good actor i
guess but i hate him i would never give
him a nickel in any movie ever
why is that how do we decide when we
separate the art from the politics of
the actor or musician shalom brother
right shalom to the eggman i think it's
a very personal decision there's no rule
one way or the other
it has been weeks if not longer since we
heard from
uh whitney and she
left a number of speeches over the
weekend
so i was reading up about like where the
french are in
america
not just like the united states but like
north and south america as well
because i guess like the french invaded
mexico really long time ago
and i was just like looking that they're
like still there
um i noticed that they're also in your
candy
and all right and whitney leaving
another one
hey david
so i was wondering
if
laws don't make sense
is the police just another gang
man uh i don't know what she's talking
about i i just don't know
i want to say thank you to milo sc eggs
marshall and michael papa bush
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 14 15 and 16 today
i very much appreciate that
if you missed what happened the verdict
was announced reached
the jury convened at 3 pm just after 3
p.m eastern time
and it turns out that they didn't fill
out the form completely indicating the
amount of compensatory damages so
seemingly
they the jury has found damages for
someone
we don't yet know who
and the jury has been sent back out to
write that number in now it's possible
it was an oversight and it's a matter of
just real quick writing it down that's a
possibility
at the same time maybe the jury didn't
even talk about it and now they're going
to have to be there for hours or maybe
even days figuring out what is the
dollar amount
we just don't know
dave thoughts on the sussman verdict
will durham do more prosecutions or is
this the end of the witch hunt well
we're taking it verdict by verdict i
have a segment on today's podcast about
the sussman verdict trump uh trump
absolutely lost it on um
on truth central truth essential saying
that it was all biased and you can't get
a fair trial in dc and all this
different stuff crazy crazy stuff
i mean they did the due process that the
republicans claim to want and now
trump's like no it was invalid
it's it's nuts
so we'll have that on it's on today's
podcast
and you can uh
i think it's already out maybe or it
should be out momentarily
um okay
pizza man drc has grabbed the twitch
prime subscription and is number 17. i
very much appreciate that
can't uh can't go wrong with that
um
did i see the good liars thing of course
i did of course i did let i'll actually
show it to you guys now we do have a
segment
on the podcast today
this is truly one of the best things
that i've seen our friends davram
stiffler
and jason selvig are the good liars
i will present this to you without
introduction just check this out this is
really really interesting more people
and more crime is committed and more
people are killed with hammers every
year than guns
look at the facts i i will look that up
i don't think that's true actually it's
true in the united states though sir
that is true look it up it's on you can
google it
it's true it's actually google it
so the number of murder victims and the
weapons used okay number one
handguns
8029 number two firearms type not stated
4863 number three knives are cutting
instruments personal weapons
fists feet
uh then rifles
at 455. then blunt objects clubs hammers
uh
393. the the 300 the hammers that stat
is just wrong back to your question
second amendment is still my right and
it's still important to me
[Laughter]
so the whole reason you cited about
dangerous hammers
is debunked so it no longer matters and
you still have your same opinion okay
very that's basically it it looks like
we are back
or maybe we will be soon we it it seems
as though something is happening
and we're right exactly the point is the
facts don't really matter what matters
is my opinion
and uh you know
maybe the facts coincide with your
opinion or maybe they don't
jason asks via super chat are you at all
surprised by the latest durham news
not i mean listen i didn't follow that
particular case so i don't know
um i mean there was due process there
were charges there was a trial there
were deliberations and the jury
acquitted that that's due process that's
the way it works
um i don't i don't know what else can
really be said about it
johnny depp not in the courtroom as you
guys can see apparently he's in london i
don't know
yeah i guess he doesn't have to be there
which is it is a little strange
it is a little bit strange
but
alas
it is what it is
let's listen
i'm guessing the fact that everybody's
still sitting here
and the cameras are back on in the
courtroom means that this was a very
short
technicality
i don't know why the video quality is so
poor it's poor on all of the feeds it's
not on my end it's on the feed end
thank you to coffee nub for the twitch
prime subscription your new subscriber
number 18 today
and i uh
very much appreciate that
let's see what else we have here
uh new voicemail
hey david you know i was just thinking
with
my name's blake
oh this is so bad
what the hell
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry all right
all right the court is back in
at least something that caught
the eye
and let's see if in the meantime we can
get a better feed oh the feed has just
gotten better
okay here we go
we are back
thanks milo for gifting five
subscriptions i appreciate that very
much
the jury is coming back in
the judge expected to admonish the jury
to comment like and subscribe to my feed
i'm sure
thanks to adam gingrich for gifting a
subscription appreciate that adam
the moment many of us have been waiting
for
so that this ends
i'm ready for it to be over quite quite
frankly folks
youtube has been taken over by this
something is wrong with my hair i don't
know what it is but
i apologize
all right is it unanimous
thank you sir
i can't hear a thing
the the audio is just a disaster
in civil case number cl 2019
2911
mr depp's claim against ms heard
one as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled amber heard i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath
that has to change
in the washington post online edition
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath
that has to change end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes wow
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard answer yes
the state question the statement was
about mr depp answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
there it is question the statement has a
defamatory implication about mr depp
answer yes oh man
question the
defamatory implication was designed and
intended by ms heard
answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication to
someone who saw it other than mr death
answer yes wow
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice
answer yes wow
as to the statement appearing in the
op-ed entitled a transformative moment
for women in the washington post print
edition
and the online op-ed amber heard i spoke
up against sexual violence and faced our
culture's wrath that has to change
in the washington post online edition
quote then two years ago i became a
public figure
representing domestic abuse and i felt
the full force of our culture's wrath
for women who speak out end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes oh boy
has mr debt proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard
answer yes
question the statement was about mr depp
answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr depp
answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes
ma'am question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr depp
answer yes
do you find that mr depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence
that ms heard acted with actual malice
answer yes
she's done
three as to the statement appearing in
the op-ed entitled a transformative
moment for women in the washington post
print edition
and the online op-ed
amber heard i spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's rat
that has to change
in the washington post online edition
quote i had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse end quote
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr debt proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms hurd
answer yes
question the statement was about mr deck
answer yes
question
the statement was false answer yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about mr deb
answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by ms heard
answer yes wow
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of this
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication
to someone who saw it other than mr
death
answer yes
do you find that mr death has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that ms
heard acted with actual malice answer
yes
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars wow
as against amber heard
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of five million dollars 15
million
in civil case number cl
2019
2911
ms heard's claim against mr death here
we go now it's the other one
as to this statement appearing in the
april 8 2020
online edition of the daily mail quote
amber heard and her friends in the media
use fake sexual violence allegations
as both a sword and shield
depending on their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as the sword
and flick inflicting them on the public
and mr depp
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer no oh boy
two
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27th wow 2020 online edition of
the daily mail
quote
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt did not do the
trick the officers came to the
penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and publicist
and then placed a second call to 9-1-1
end quote
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes oh
has ms heard proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question mr waldman while acting as
an agent for mr death
made or published the statement
answer yes okay
question the statement was about
misheard answer yes
question the statement was seen by
someone other than misheard answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
do you find that ms heard has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that the
statement by mr waldman was made with
actual malice
answer yes
three
as to this statement appearing in the
april 27
2020 online edition of the daily mail
quote
we've reached the beginning of the end
of miss herd's abuse hoax against johnny
depp end quote
do you find that ms heard has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer no oh
as against john c depp ii we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of two million dollars wow okay as
against john c depp ii
we the jury award punitive damages in
the amount of zero dollars wow
does either side wish to have the jury
pulled yes your honor all right jamie
members of the jury if this is your
verdict please answer yes
if this is not your verdict please
answer no
juror number six
juror number 10
juror number 15
juror number 16
your juror number 22 yeah
jarrod number 27
gerald number 29
yes
i do find that the jury's verdict is
unanimous ladies and gentlemen this
concludes your service in this case i
want to thank you again for your
dedication and your hard work during
this trial i know i speak for everybody
here uh when i appreciate tell you that
we appreciate your sacrifices and your
time and your public service in this
matter okay so i'm going to have you go
back to the jury deliberation room for
one more
time and then we'll release you from
there okay all right thank you
wow
we'll explain everything in a second
all right
okay in accordance with law i will amend
the punitive damages
award to the statutory cap of 350
thousand dollars on mr depp's award okay
um i will set this down for entry of an
order and can we do it on june 24th at
10 a.m if that's available
all right mr two if you could prepare
that order and then circulate it to mrs
brederhoff and we can have all the
objections noted on it all right
thank you very much all right and if i
get it before that date i'll take it off
the docket okay all right again thank
you to all the attorneys uh for your
professionalism and uh you're welcome to
come to my courtroom anytime well give
me a few weeks but then you can come any
time okay all right report is adjourned
thank you
wow all right
what a finally completed result and you
might have heard that little thing at
the end about we're going to limit the
punitive damages that's an important
element as well
so here's the bottom line
three assertions of of defamation
against amber heard
three assertions of defamation against
johnny depp as amber heard now leaves
the courtroom
defeated quite frankly
okay
the jury found that amber heard was
defamatory in all three of the
statements she made about johnny depp
the jury found that johnny depp was
defamatory in one of the three
statements made about
amber heard
in terms of damages the jury awarded
johnny depp
10 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 5 million dollars in
punitive damages by statute punitive
damages are limited to three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars meaning that
instead of fifteen million amber heard
owns owes johnny depp
ten million three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars okay so 10.35 million
meanwhile the jury awarded amber heard
two million dollars in compensatory
damages and zero in terms of punitive
damages so you take the 10.35 that he
that she owes him
you subtract out it's sort of like you
know how on my website you can use the
coupon code obama and get a discount
she gets a 2 million discount as it were
instead of owing 10.35 million she will
only owe 8.35 million now my
understanding is her net worth is 8
million dollars and you know these
things can vary
i don't know you know who knows how
reliable those different websites are
um but that's basically the end of of
that
the real winners here are johnny depp's
attorneys quite frankly i mean listen
all of the attorneys i think get paid i
mean i don't think amber heard's lawyers
would have been doing this on
contingency i don't believe
uh but needless to say
um
johnny depp's lawyers not only
probably get a slice of that although
maybe they had a fixed fee i just don't
know don't know enough about that
but
particularly ben chu and camille vazquez
have dramatically raised their profiles
as litigators and probably now i mean
not not that ben chu necessarily needed
it
but uh they will they will certainly be
uh profiting handsomely from future
legal work i think is fair to say
matt gates on a ford bronco says next
sequel pirates of the caribbean don't
marry damsels in distress just regular
ones especially after drinking all the
rum wow
that's big time stuff
i want to say a huge thank you to
darlene astalos for signing up on my
website joinpacman.com
with the coupon code obama obama we are
presumably shortly going to be hearing
from the attorneys i mean listen if if
what it what a disaster quite frankly
for amber heard imagine having to sit
through all of this
and and testify and all of everything is
just exposed
uh your private business you presumably
have to pay your lawyers
and you end up owing eight million
dollars i mean it's uh it is really
quite a scene really quite a scene
um
hi david susan from chicago um you're
commenting on the johnny depp trial and
the only thing that people are talking
about in the chat is your hair
so you might want people look
yeah
no it's definitely a problem i can't
really understand what's happening
bye
it's uh hold on let me see if we can fix
it
yep
no it's we're definitely having an issue
as far as that goes
uh all right we're gonna be hearing from
the attorneys momentarily
thanks to juan for gifting a membership
on my website that's number
30 which i very very much appreciate
uh let's see what's being said
is pretty amazing remember this is a
case where he sued a publication in
london where the standard is harder to
win and a judge came back and said no we
he believed right
the richard says via super chat the grab
him by the purses crowd won the day
um in a sense in a sense that is
absolutely true
thanks to juan for gifting another
membership on my website that's number
31.
adam gingrich sending a 20 super chat
and um
earmarking those funds for hair styling
gel right absolutely absolutely actually
you know what in all seriousness we're
i'm interviewing jamie raskin in 10
minutes
and uh i actually do need to fix my hair
because it would be horribly
embarrassing if jamie raskin who's
running the january 6 committee hearing
sees my hair like this so i actually am
going to end my stream now this is going
to be a really great interview with
jamie raskin i'm so excited that we got
him on the show it is a major major get
for us
real quick in the chat any questions for
jamie raskin that i should ask
well i'm interviewing him in 10 minutes
i got to go get ready for it
anybody have anything i will ask him if
he would allow me to be his press
secretary if he runs for president
absolutely
um he's not going to say anything about
about running for president i assure you
no way
a lot of you guys seem to want him to
run
ask him about the keystone pipeline well
okay maybe
is he going to sue all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines all right it seems people so
listen i'm going to ask him what we can
expect when it comes to the january 6
committee hearings i will ask him
whether he expects any members of
congress to be prosecuted that's that's
a great question we will ask him about
that all right everybody thank you for
joining me see you very soon